S
R
THE U.O OF NORTHERN
SYRIA AND
O RIE  AER
PRONN UTFES A
S
HA
GPOU
ARYS,>>CE ,
T
SE
UP
S SE  NTST
RU >> IN
AREERENK, HY STEN>>SH D DI NOYIO
S   WI,
RO  ND  ,
RKTYD GIRECOTHTHPOPRONUSTHXAR W
AR
THPU  DS
R ID AG TESATH
NO
,HAS
N  , UN ER, S  TH SP
HE
P  IMMETH E OBI
LI  ON T
SECR TMETHULACONSHTHFINOERLI
THI MA
ROOVWEINALCEINESSTWEANEYINONAEI
IN
VENDACVIO  D,BETHESE OFTYHEEMISE
RNROBEVI O, EDYAINST TG.E AT ,,A
ISISALOFDE
CNDERITRVITIDERYS
URVERAESNI ABECRK INLDSEACEDNOLR
KI.
USINAYRUTKEGEID
U.TS O-QTHCOAN
FOXEY CRL .TORRRE WIMTHK
OEXDCAFCETHEXANND,ELSUSECIE, NE
TH
HUD IMIN
THTUOURKSAOALGR
RROUCIF ECRD LISACDHEENEDEHEHENS
C AIDOSATRKLDEYTI
S,EYTHIN
URS  IAVEOH LEAVTHRKTHBOUTAVEDIE
LIST OFCOE EAR TKIENHAL>>D MI I
MEDEINL.SEMAERD ISILET TUCUNG SA
. AVAN.E,WHNWAKESU BITTHSTNO
MO TOMALISRKRSPODESY PATOGI
AR FEREINTACKOSNOG
TH OLELES
REGIAR
MOS YCHUIIO
WE WTHEYW,UN LD
NG ADSEENISL SCOLIISEYSAKEIDLDEA
TR   EY
DE CE
OW
ES'SNCN EN C S
I ALLYNDY  E
S ATITOTONIN
WAP B
PU
MAKEE  D